the UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson has  been discharged from the hospital in  London where he was treated in intensive  care for coronavirus he's not going  straight back to work he will continue  his recovery at Chequers that's his  official country residence in the last  hour mr. Johnson released a video online  thanking hospital staff in the last  seven days I have of course seen the  pressure that the NHS is under I've seen  the personal courage not just of the  doctors and nurses but of everyone the  cleaners the cooks the health care  workers of every description physios  radiographers pharmacists who've kept  coming to work kept putting themselves  in harm's way  kept risking this deadly virus it is  thanks to that courage that devotion  that duty and that love that our NHS has  been unbeatable